hello America I'm Ryan Wright and I'm
Jerry today we're going to be reviewing
the trailer for the purge election year
now before we review it we will of
course watch it and due to reason I
thought we should review it first no no
no we'll talk we'll react first okay
yeah we'll react first and then we'll
see if our reaction lines up with how we
react when we actually watch it stop
yeah stop can you stop yeah sure I'll
stop stop stop
I'll stop anytime you want dude you're
still do universal meaning as there are
Dakota James to see big boy
sorry I missed the first few times
because I was [ __ ] we played a lot of
perfect games to see bigger we have just
one more is called Bobby's choice which
one of you will survive this year's the
soul of our country is at
the purge targets the poor and the
innocent the sin is going to win she
wants mcgrill changes to it is a night
that is defining our country it's
constantly something about that Senator
the purge has to come to an end take a
lot of risks I have to I was the only
one in my family to survive what we do
play this position I almost did
something on version I turn his back on
the side
I want that in all these rooms we got
eyes and ears on everything all right
let's begin cool [ __ ] I love it system
announcing the commencement of the
annual purge at the siren all crime
think soupy murder will be legal for 12
hours your government thanks you for
your participation
man whoa someone betrayed us this is not
a drill
nice penis we are
we're going right now to rival senator
come with us to drive
I've seen too much yeah bless of the
America for letting us purge and cleanse
our souls join me as we eliminate evil
or in the fat that was a little feather
they kind of showed a little much of
that yeah it showed a lotta measure that
I still think I look [ __ ] that looks
awesome
yeah it looks great like the perch
anarchy I thought was great I loved it
Ellie the first one even like the first
one's not perfect and I didn't get why
you would be let down but there's some
cool stuff in them there's some cool
stuff some cool stuff it's just not the
first movie you wanted out of this
series you wanted the second you wanted
the world yeah you wanted the world and
the purge anarchy gave us that and this
is doing an interesting kind of like
political statement stuff yeah you know
and I love how the plot is him having to
protect this woman who's trying to edit
a purge cuz she might get elected and be
able to stop this what I could go for
why he would be that sort of nut like it
makes sense to bring him back yeah yeah
yeah like I get why this guy might have
a job like that this is a very impactful
moment in his life if you wouldn't go
back just being a normal guy I don't
like Zack makes sense and he's clearly
good at that kind of work and it seems
at least for part of it again like I do
think they went a little far into the
plot to show us things but it seems cool
that they're kind of combining at least
for some of it Butler's movie diversity
sighs yeah thing enough cuz they're like
holed up in the White House so I got
imagine there gonna be some cool
invasion stuff there you know get cuz
there was some good invasion stuff in
the first movie so yeah that but it's a
different kind of invasion because you
see the main characters in the first one
it was unexpected for them this one
they're anticipating an invasion and it
makes the plot interesting someone
betrayed them who did betray them who's
know I want to know beyond that like
when they gets into the violence I feel
like it's gonna be [ __ ] vitally well
that's the thing too is is like on the
flip side it looks like you'll have some
of the stuff from both movies and the
city stuff looks even bigger than the
second movie it makes the purge look
even bigger and even more menacing and
the thing is they found a reason to have
like creepy weird masks and people
behaving strangely and they found a way
to motivate that so it works yeah so
it's like you can throw in as many cool
weird fucked-up Maps as you want and
it's not distracting the whole KissMe
thing in the knee
on Statue of Liberty like those are
freaky as hell it looks scary and they
are violent I want to say you're making
all great points now I'm gonna put you
on the spot yeah yeah I'm trying to get
Jerry to look at you guys more I'm so
sorry
it's a part of connecting with people on
YouTube
a little trick I don't connected anybody
and you keep looking at me a little too
much you know you want to balance it out
like right now we're gonna go to Skype
I'm looking back at the camera of course
is I hearing for your approval Ryan so I
need to check is constantly cuz I can't
check that well you got it just include
them you know like what if this was a
third person in the room and then they
just felt left out of the conversation
yeah that's fair I'm sorry guys I didn't
mean to do that
personalizing this channel talk directly
to you yeah yeah I'm not gonna blink you
don't ever look at me I'm not gonna
blink
there's too much of looking at me now
you gotta go the other extreme to
understand how to do it yeah this looks
like it could be the best purge movie it
hasn't they have potential to anyway I
mean like what oh I'm so sorry already
I mean strike one Jerry it definitely
has potential I hope that they can pay
off and really dig into their political
implications cuz you know like you can
use horror and genre pieces as a way of
making social commentary and I hope this
movie doesn't cop out on that basically
it's all I want like great job
hey don't like pretty much you were just
looking at the camera thanks man I was
great it was great thank you okay I got
a question for you that I want you to
direct at them okay I've had people tell
me why do you like movies like the purge
I mean that just sounds sick and
sinister why would you want to get
yourself through that experience as a
horror enthusiast I would love to know
and please let them know - why you like
the purge or the concept at least well I
don't know I mean first and foremost
what it often boils down to me is like
regardless of the purpose if eclis it's
like if I know all this stuff is fiction
it's not real
you just know so already it doesn't
quite bother me so much as like if I
know something is real you know it's
like we see documentary footage of
violence I react very differently
because you know
but with this stuff like you know it's a
fantasy and it's like a dark look at at
a potential version of the future no
matter how convoluted and that's kind of
fascinating it's both you know like
there's an intellectual curiosity about
like oh like this story could be cool
and then there's also just the aesthetic
like I like things that are a little
darker that are a little more strange or
menacing because you know horror is a--
is a safe environment to explore unsafe
emotions yeah
or uncomfortable emotions and i think
that's fun sometimes and then you know
there's the very surface stuff like
whose myth so cool act kills but for me
I mean even the purge movies are dark to
me like don't fun horror movie no not at
all
um and sometimes you can be cool oh yeah
they can't even be really cool
in the same way that like Jason Bourne
is cool where you're like ah that looks
like it hurt a lot but it's still like
he really knows what he's doing so you
watch the second one like Frank Grillo
is like that it's like man that looks
like it hurt very much but he's really
good at this James and Monica has done
all three purge movies and I feel like
he's really the guy for this cuz after
the first one I was like okay they could
probably get another person to make the
second one better and they brought him
back and I was like really that was a
kind of letdown but you see that this
guy really knows the world that's the
cool thing about this horror about this
I don't want to call a [ __ ] I don't
that's what I mean it's not only a
horror movie it is it is but it's not
your choice yeah not like because the
horror is the monster is just the most
bass and aggressive parts of humanity
yeah your worst at this game that's you
know and that's what makes it terrifying
in a lot of ways because it's weirdly
psychological not weirdly but it's
strongly psychological in that sense
it's totally it's not your traditional
horde but it's totally scary to think if
you eat even if it's convoluted you
think to yourself if they actually did
this yeah this would be [ __ ]
terrifying I would want to hold that
house I would not survive purge night
like I just probably wouldn't unless you
go crazy I like how the second one
touched on me I feel like this one will
touch on it a lot more of the debate
about um you know is murder okay to be
legal because well it's all about class
we've wandered that you know like but
what they have going on besides just
crying it's like their theory is is like
you know
if everybody just gets one day where
there are no consequences you could do
whatever you know people will be less
itchy the rest of the year maybe you can
get that TV and you don't have to worry
about or maybe you can take out some
aggression in a very cathartic way and
then not have to worry about it for a
while but the thing they've done here I
mean that's [ __ ] up in its own way but
what they've done here they've also made
it a class thing where it's like you
have the wealthy people who can live
above the perch even though everybody
kind of tile of it's a war or you have
you know the regular people on the
ground you know the the middle and low
class people who are like struggling and
in the thick of it you know and it's
it's become like a class thing and
that's what could be very relevant if
they really double down because the
second one seemed like it had some ideas
like like it wanted to kind of touch
socio-political ideas with this metaphor
and now I'm hoping especially the light
of all the craziness with the election
going on right now like that this can be
a nice like that they will dig into them
yeah make that crucial to the story
aside so actively and politically
relevant yeah cuz I mean they're taking
somebody who is railing against the
Purdue wants to change things and
they're putting her directly in the
situation I get the sense again so you
know that does things to a person so
that could be an interesting emotional
story and I hope that they also you know
don't don't you know don't cop out for
popcorn on being relevant and also frank
grillo pretty badass well I'm like two
and a half minutes I'm sorry it was good
staring at the camera no I mean of you
talking oh sorry
who's good like two and a half minutes
I'll stop talking I was looking at the
timer on the camera I'll stop talking
now no no it's only in a minute it's a
minute cuz I had to cut it in the middle
as you talked thought you meant this
time I'm sorry I'll stop what I'm
excited no I like it I like it I like
pointing out things about you like
thanks man I usually point out whenever
I come into somebody's like place for
the first time that's usually I just
point out stuff about their thing like
wow that's a cool poster evidence I like
your poster this is a cool wall here
yeah just Jerry anyway guys listen we're
gonna watch that movie keep a lookout
for them if you're new to the channel
subscribe today become a reject ah
I can never get over the fact that I
named fans like it's just if there's
anything I've ever done that feels like
selling out it's that you guys naming
naming the fans I just don't like
feeling like a sellout disposable
e-cigarettes these are great because you
have to worry about keep refilling them
they just you have this like space
station thing here hey what are you
doing oh just to talk about this they
did reason tsageri and dan calf Stubbs
is on this channel you [ __ ] now we lost
$500 I'm sorry we lost fine no way to
fix this no I don't believe on water
vanity I didn't know that you didn't
tell him
yeah smoke that [ __ ]